so what I wanted to do here was take a
day to focus on indie comics and I
figured if I'm going to jump into this
realm why not start with the most
successful independent comic book
franchise of all time spawn
so the roots of Swan actually come as
fallout from the relationship between
county book creators and County book
publishing companies also before we saw
this video I just want to say that no
todd mcfarlane
and Seth MacFarlane are not related to
one another having said that if you
recall my video on Howard the Duck we
had talked about how Steve Gerber's
lawsuit against Marvel over the
ownership of Howard set the standard for
defining a new relationship between
creators writers and comic book
publishers the sidetrack for a second
prior to Steve Gerber most all comic
book creators were considered workers
for hire what this means is that they're
basically contractors that can work for
Marvel DC or any number of other
book publishing companies at the time is
Steve Gerber work for Marvel the
relationship between creators incoming
book publishers was one-sided and that
when a creators work was handed over to
appear in a comic their rights to that
character went with it
when Steve Gerber had created Howard the
Duck in 1973 and was fired for his
inability to meet deadlines in 1978 the
rights of Howard's ducks stayed with
Marvel and so in 1980 when Steve river
learned that Marvel intended to
capitalize on Howard's incredible
popularity by launching a film Steve
Gerber filed a lawsuit alleging that he
was the creator and sole owner of the
character while Steve Gerber would go on
to lose his lawsuit
the fallout allowed for the creation of
something called a creators Bill of
Rights
although creators were still maintained
under work-for-hire laws among the
whites outlined and the creators Bill of
Rights was profit sharing where creators
were previously paid a set amount based
on their popularity and their ability to
bargain under the creators Bill of
Rights content creators now had the
ability to share in the profits of sales
relating to their work transitioning
back to Todd McFarlane this system of
profiteering was one of the contributing
factors that led to his leaving Marvel
and DC and subsequent creation of spawn
and 1979 when Todd McFarlane tried to
enter the comic book scene his efforts
came in the form of around 700 pinup
submissions spent in the course of
several months which were sent to both
DC and Marvel while most rejected his
work
DC's editor and talent coordinator sow
Amendola responded to MacFarlane by
informing him that rather than sitting
in pinups he should send in a short
series written and designed by
MacFarlane himself
to this end in 1981 he wrote Andrew a
story called coyote assuming on a Native
American orphan following the death of
his parents during a nuclear test the
story followed the young man as he
eventually became aware coyote able to
shape-shift turn invisible by performing
a ritual all while living in the desert
and killing those who entered his domain
while not the greatest of thoughts the
story was submitted to uncanny x-men
editor and Musante who handed the
publication over to Archie Goodwin and
Joe Duffy publishing the title under
Marvel's epic imprint a precursor to the
adult-oriented lineup found at Marvel
max Steve Englehart reached out to Todd
McFarlane and offered him a position as
an artist with his work officially on
the landscape of a major publication
between 1985 and 1987 Todd McFarlane
drew for both DC and Marvel working as a
cover illustrator and artists alongside
a veritable who's who of writers
including Peter David Mike W bar and
David Nicolini Todd McFarlane's two-year
run included Batman year two a four-part
story in the pages of Detective Comics
issues 575 through 578 as a follow-up to
Frank Miller's critically acclaimed
Batman year one as well as The
Incredible Hulk issues 331 through 345
because his depiction of comic book
characters brought a level of detail
that had only been seen by a handful of
artists like John Byrne McFarland's art
style garnered him a massive fan
following as a result in 1988 Todd
McFarlane was assigned to Marvel's
flagship character with amazing
spider-man issue number 298 continuing a
style of detailed art combined with a
sort of surrealism and character design
under Todd McFarlane spider-man's
physical appearance and webbing were
given a bit of a darker and grittier
appearance something that was adored by
fans at the time furthermore by 1990
McFarlane was able to negotiate his way
into becoming writer and artist for a
separate series titled spider-man with
issue number one selling 2.5 million
copies however by 1991 the fallout from
Steve grippers Howard deduct lawsuit and
the stance that creators should maintain
complete control over their work had
reached a fever pitch while creators
were sharing in the profits of comics
sales the percentage paid was only a
small fraction of what companies were
making moreover because the work by Todd
McFarlane among others were being
marketed heavily including the release
of variant covers spurring record sales
the pay of Todd McFarlane and others
largely remain unchanged and that they
were making the same money as an
whose comics worth selling that well as
a result alongside Rob Liefeld Jim Lee
Eric Larson Jim Valentino and Marc
Silvestri Todd McFarlane founded Image
Comics under the new brand image had two
main rules creators would maintain
complete ownership of their work
allowing them to take their products
with them when they left and as an
extension of the first rule the second
rule was that Image Comics would not
interfere creatively or financially with
the efforts of creators and a 1992
interview with the comic Journal Todd
McFarlane had stated that with image
comics officially formed the company
needed a flagship character to launch
the brand because relatable characters
and anti-heroes where something fans
seemed to latch on to and were the
highest sellers MacFarlane sought to
combine both by introducing a normal man
thrust into an insane situation who
would fight for the same things as
heroes but take a darker approach taking
place in the first four issues title
questions the origin story of spawn is
originally given to us in bits and
pieces what I mean here is that these
stories simply picks up with spawn on
earth having no idea who he is or what
happened to him as he explains
flashbacks occur periodically but only
provide fragments of information and his
first flashback he sees the images of an
unknown woman along with his funeral but
as the images come into sharper view and
he begins to recollect his own funeral
he comes to the realization that five
years have passed since his funeral and
the present moment with the woman he's
seeing in the flashbacks being his wife
although we doesn't remember her name
coming to the conclusion that the only
way for him to actually pieces life back
together and understand what happened to
him rest and locating and visiting his
wife he sets out to locate and speak
with her following this spawn has a
flashback where he recalls that after
dying a bargain was struck with a demon
named albuja who granted him powers but
at the price of his soul at this point
he begins experimenting with his
abilities realizing that he can use his
powers to change his appearance
spawn Morse's face into a younger person
but after realizing that he can't change
his appearance back to the way he used
to he begins to lash out and changing
back into his decrepit form he has a
third flashback well the first vision
was about a woman and the second was
about
selling his soul to a demon the third
vision is about a man that he remembers
name Jason Wynn what we're told is that
Jason Wynn had initially served as a
mentor to spawn under the tutelage of
Jason Wynn spawn learned to become an
expert killer in the military and later
as part of the CIA
however as his time engaging in black
ops missions increased he began to
realize that rather than performing
legitimate actions on behalf of the
government instead he was helping to
cover up illegal activities and so when
spawn confronted Jason about his actions
he learned that not only was he right
but Jason seemed to enjoy the pain that
he was causing others now following this
flashback spawn passes out and after
waking up comes face to face with a
violator now initially we're not given
any information on why the violator is
here or what his purposes but as he's
presented to us the violator seems to be
a comedic element in the spawned series
making a series of off-color remarks the
violator prepares his Hellspawn why he's
there but begins to descend into a
discussion on the various ways he could
kill him in addition to this the goofy
nature of the violator is expanded on
when he reveals that he has to use a
bathroom in the middle of his
explanation and seemingly defecates in
the alleyway after finishing and
continuing his explanation on how
dangerous he is
spawn becomes fed up and simply walks
away shortly after though spawn realizes
that the name of the woman he was
looking for it is actually Wanda Blake
appeasing his memories of Jason when
together spawn realizes that as a former
employee of the CIA the organization
would have a complete file on himself as
well as Wanda after going to the offices
and taking the file he begins to skim
through and realizes that Wanda had
moved from her parents house in Staten
Island to Queens New York
traveling to Queens and changing his
entire appearance he approaches the
house of Wanda and after ringing the
doorbell and meeting Wanda face to face
since his death he finds himself both
stunned and enamoured about how
beautiful she is
Clemmy to be part of an organization
called the SPLA which is a stand-in for
the real world group the ASPCA he uses
the excuse that his reason for being
there is to offer a licensing option for
the family pet should they become lost
however partway through their
conversation Wanda is met with the
arrival of her daughter realizing that
the diagnosis from doctors of their
inability to have children when he was
alive was due to the fact that spawn
couldn't produce children
he becomes overwhelmed by this fact and
color
apses after coming to he finds himself
in the living room of Wanda's house at
which point we get a little more
backstory on the aftermath of spawns
death and the life of Wanda Blake what
we're told is that spawns real name is
Al Simmons and that the report issued a
Wanda was that he died in the line of
duty however because he had been part of
the CIA the specifics of his death were
never revealed due to issues of national
security furthermore during the five
years between the time Al Simmons died
and the current moment Wanda and his
best friend Terry Fitzgerald grieved
together and during the time fell in
love at which point they produced a
child named cyan referring to Wanda but
using a non-existent person as a
stand-in
Simmons states that he was married once
but that he and his wife had gone
separate ways and that she doesn't know
anything about him anymore but
furthermore rather than getting in the
way in intruding in her new life Simmons
ends the conversation by walking away
and wishing the two a good afternoon
following the revelation that Wanda had
started over and that his life as it
stands now is a shadow of his former
self and that he's destined to isolation
sponsor his vengeance against mal Bhoja
and stating that all he wanted was to be
with his wife again however during his
rants Ponce interrupted by the return of
the violator having previously been on a
series of murders in the city of New
York the violator killed his victims by
ripping their hearts out of their chests
engaging in a battle with spawn the
violator tears his heart from his chest
but realizes the spawn has power given
to him directly by mal Borgia allowing
him to live without a human heart after
engaging in a brutal and violent battle
in an alleyway the violator explains
that the reason he's there is to monitor
spawn and teach him how to use his
powers what he also says is that spawn
seems to be some measure of the chosen
one in the eyes of mal Bhoja although we
don't know how beginning is lessons to
spawn on the use of his abilities the
violator and Swann engage in a vicious
battle in the alley that costs upon his
arm
however the conflicts broken up with the
arrival of not Bossier himself as he
explains the purpose of Al Simmons being
transformed into Swann was to lead Malvo
Joe's army of condemned Souls against
God because Al Simmons killed so many
people when he was alive and because he
possessed a combination of ruthlessness
brashness and arrogance combined with
his atheism when he died his soul was
captured by mal Bhoja while later
appearances a spawn would show him
having godlike abilities in the early
comics Vaughn had the ability to project
energy to heal from almost any injury
and shape-shift but these abilities came
with a caveat either he can use his
powers against Malvo
attending to in villainy which will
result in his powers burning out and
it's all being damned for eternity or we
can refuse to use those powers and do
nothing which would lead to damnation if
mal Bhoja is successfully able to take
over the world and destroy God and so
it's mal bozhe prepares to leave he can
finds a violator to his human form due
to the fact that his series of murders
is keeping criminals cautious and
because of that they're not killing each
other and expanding mal bages army and
so as mal budget of parts and the origin
story of spawn comes to a close spawn
dawns a hat in a trench coat taking time
to soak in the events and determining
whether or not he'll fight for or
against mal Bhoja with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and let me know what other kind of
independent comic books you guys are
interested in seeing and that will catch
you guys on here peace